[Applause]
look
interesting story out jack harlow white
rapper calm down akash
calm down mark okay conda mark likes
come on bro
mark likes jack harlow yeah mark loves
he loves the harlot that's his boy so
jack harlow was in atlanta
and um some gays wanted to know what was
popping for real
he was walking down the street and they
were shooting their shot
and i guess he was shocked maybe there's
not a lot of gays in louisville or
something like that but
it brought up a very interesting uh
question
at least for me right which was
is homophobia
wrong
no we've had this discussion we had a
discussion about a different phobia last
week
right okay so what i guess to clarify
the parameters just to make sure we're
good
i'm not talking about homophobia in
terms of um
hatred hatred in terms of the way that
people assume what that word means but
phobia is fear
literally fear arachnophobia fear of
spiders spiders
right hydrophobia fear of water wheat
what hydra
oh yeah water yeah yeah i don't hate
water
agoraphobic fear of i think leaving
outdoors
outdoors okay so it's truly a crippling
fear
right homophobia
i don't know if that's hateful i do
believe
it's arrogant
not in this case wait for it okay
homophobia implies that the gay dudes
would do something to you they would
induce fear
simply complimenting you is not scary
but women when guys are talking to them
and coming towards them
you have every right to be scared taylor
because that guy could do something
crazy
he could assault you he could even rape
you that is terrifying he could
overpower you he could overpower you you
could be male phobic you could be
whatever
heterophobic or whatever that is male
phobic yes okay finish your points
okay so my point is homophobia
if there's a gaggle of gays
they're standing on the corner right and
they
are whistling at you and then they start
to approach you all together
if a guy is homophobic right that's
i am fearful that these gays might rape
me i don't think that is
hateful but it is arrogant to assume
that they would want
to [ __ ] you and [ __ ] you forcefully
getting laid is one of the easiest
things about being gay
right i mean isn't that what happens
isn't that the good thing about being
gay you're in the
shower at the gym and you're like yo
you're not stuck in dick and the guy's
like yeah that's right and then
yeah right like isn't that that's just
how it goes that's how
i think that's how it works i mean aids
didn't go around so fast because they
don't [ __ ]
at all i mean this is male sex driving
right they have glory holes right
they have glory holes there's just a
hole where you pull your dick in and
then it just gets sucked and on the
other side there's a guy who's like
thank god
a dick and no face this is all i wanted
right yeah so yeah that [ __ ] sounds
magical son
you just push your dick in this hole
can we just talk about something okay
narnia over there you know what you know
what gay means before it meant
homosexual
happy happy i think you're dick sucked
all the time
probably that means that the people that
decide to call homosexuals gay
were not going ew gay they were going
man look how gay
look how happy that must be just getting
your dick sucked all the time in a sauna
you know if you imagine the straight
dude and somebody's like stick your dick
in that hole you'd be like you're you're
[ __ ] mine
no there's a guy's mouth on the other
side what
sick maybe they're just thought if he
doesn't have a beard
gay people are so trusting and so they
be getting their dick sucked so much
like yo if i just put a hole in this
bathroom stall
yes and i put my dick in there somebody
can suck it so here's the problem with
homophobia
it's too arrogant these gay guys can get
dick whenever they want think about it
they can get so straight guys we're
walking around
going like oh my god these guys you guys
are going to rape me thinking you're
going to get raped by a gay guy
who could [ __ ] whenever he wants right
and guys who are in great shape these
gay guys are working out all the [ __ ]
time
probably because they're going to start
again of course i go to the gym all the
time
i was just getting my dick sucked in the
shower and it makes perfect sense
the point is homophobic protein shakes
this is the real protein
so here's the thing it is arrogant but
not
hateful based on the literal definition
of the word correct
does that make sense if you're tracking
them now the one thing i would say is
yeah you said women give me pushback or
as they say fun
you say women are afraid because a man
can overpower them correct
if you're a gay dude you could probably
overpower most straight dudes
i mean these [ __ ] are where
you're at
west hollywood these guys are beautiful
and they are chiseled and they're
massive i mean
you sound very turned on by it and
they're tight and they're just nice and
smart and they're
successful
they're talented and they listen to me
and they listen to me
and they cook i mean they're great guys
but yeah you're making points if they
want to have their way with you they can
so if you're jack harlow jack harlow
built like an 80s gay
these modern day games will easily
overpower 80s gay jack harlow yeah he's
got ricky's before they're in the gym
all the time getting their immune system
up
yes talking so this is so
maybe homophobia should be a function of
height
like if you're a little dude and cute as
[ __ ]
yeah right you could be more afraid
of gay dudes potentially doing something
to you
that you want you have a right to be
more homophobic than i do
right every gay dude on this earth could
probably have his way with me exactly i
would
let him but that's the only difference
but does that make a little sense like i
wonder if gay guys ever push back on the
idea of homophobia where they're like
dude we don't even want to [ __ ] you like
that's the most insulting thing
like straight guys like all these gay
guys wanted me what are you talking
about
oh sex is the easiest thing to get why
do i even care about what you get
they're hitting on you and then you're
like yo
chill out and they're like that's
homophobic what makes you think i want
to [ __ ] you was like you were just
that's like a construction worker
when a girl's like stop hitting on me be
like i didn't wanna [ __ ] you i just
wanna whistle at you [ __ ] stupid that's
what they want
um if the girl literally stopped and was
like all right let's leave leave work so
let's go [ __ ] i think the construction
workers be like well i i was just trying
to
entertain got buildings my friends it's
corona i can't get tested if i leave the
facility it's a whole issue
i don't think they've ever done that you
think they're just gonna walk off the
work
i don't think women have been like let's
[ __ ] right now
yeah but i'm sure if they did you would
have to go you can't be the gay dude
being like
well no actually maybe on my lunch break
have you ever reacted like a
construction worker whistled
at you and you were like well what do
you want to do
um not necessarily that talking to the
microphone not necessarily that way
well how what way did it work like as in
like if they were whistling or like hey
what's up my like i'll just do a weird
ass face or something like that but have
you ever been into it
but it's never worked right like the the
flirtation has never worked you've never
been like oh here's my number thank you
so much for whistling at me
and they know that i don't get why why
do you guys do that
it's the same reason why like shamu like
puts the water on the people watching
it's just fun you know what i mean it's
just entertainment yeah but the people
making
gags people will sit in the splash zone
women don't intentionally
yeah like i don't know what you're doing
trying to walk around in the city yeah
no no no no no no no you're not
answering this yeah
what are you doing the kitchen
what do you do when you go on the splash
zone put on a poncho that's right over
up
cover it up head to toe i will go
out looking above me as hell and then
there'll still be guys that hit on me
they like make you wrong
don't they make you feel good because
like you know i don't look right like
stop
but man imagine you look right imagine
how much more you would get maybe they
see what's beautiful on the inside
fat yeah maybe they're cackling maybe a
menorah
sounds like a constellation bro that's
like
a little dipper that's what the labia
menorah is
no that's the jewish labia
[Applause]
this is crazy he said lightning a
menorah what's this
that's a hanukkah oh hanukkah light the
menorah i thought you were saying like
light me a menorah i was like this guy's
really want something i don't know
what's happening right now bro
it's all good you never smell anything
right anyway she's looking at taylor's
notes just looks like she's pounding her
face on the phone
spell my name for [ __ ] i know how do you
spell out
you